[Applause]
welcome back to another episode of down
the middle i'm so pleased today to have
my second guest from double line after
after jeffrey gundlach come and visit
with us bill campbell
bill is the portfolio manager for
international fixed income at double
line which runs upwards of 140 billion
dollars a huge credit shop obviously
uh and if you if you want to put it in
layman's terms bill handles all of their
currency and global interest rate uh
strategies and therefore he has to have
a very broad view of the world and a
good understanding of the interactions
between interest rates and currencies
and how that plays out uh
i won't walk you through his entire
resume
he's got everything that he should have
economics international business
mathematics you name it but he's also
got
uh a bachelor's in english
uh from pen from penn state and i'm i'm
gonna first of all bill welcome
it's great to have you thank you thank
you for having me on this is uh really a
treat well uh okay so why why english
help me out here
yeah no i uh so as you mentioned i was
on the economics route and uh what
started out as a few gen ed courses that
you know were interesting as far as i
enjoy literature i enjoy creative
writing uh you know kind of turned into
a few more fun courses and then uh i had
a counselor who said you know what's
with all the english and i said well i
kind of enjoy it and
then uh you know he said well
if we did a few more courses here we can
get you a ba in it and it sounded you
know sounded great to me
uh that being said uh what i thought was
just kind of uh you know
a side interest in uh undergrad turned
out to be a valuable piece of uh the
toolbox uh now that you know i'm in the
current position in the current role
that i'm in um a lot of the work we do
obviously is economics and math-based
and you know we do all of uh you know
our modeling and all of our analysis but
then we need to be able to communicate
it effectively and uh you know being
able to uh you know write and i also uh
you know think uh the
the you know the act of writing helps
you clarify your thoughts but being able
to express yourself both on paper and
verbally uh you know in a concise and
digestible format is i think a valuable
piece of uh what's required you know for
not only uh this position but for a lot
of positions so i was lucky
and i will say you write you write very
uh you write very articulately about
some very complicated subjects so it's
clearly paid off because
it's one thing to have the knowledge
it's another to be able to convey it and
and your writing certainly does a
splendid job of doing that but i'm you
know i'm i'm hoping my mom's not
watching this episode because she's
going to be saying danielle only had
nine hours left to have her her master's
in professional accounting so just mom
i'm sorry i didn't take those last three
classes so bill one up me in the english
department um
so so let take us back uh where were we
where were you raised what brought you
to pennsylvania um and who were some of
your
influences in in your studies
oh sure i actually i grew up in chicago
i grew up in northern suburb of chicago
uh called lake forest it was uh you know
a great place to grow up uh and uh you
know i when i was looking at colleges i
was looking for that college experience
that big university and uh you know that
and penn state you know offered that to
me uh you know it's a great place to
uh you know go and kind of uh uh you
know become go from a child i would say
to you know a young adult and you know
go through all of those uh you know good
experiences academically and socially
uh that you you really get in a big
college town uh but when it came time to
graduate uh you know obviously i was on
the economics track i you know had a
little bit of english and you know i was
trying to and i was coming into you know
the 2000 2001 job market which was um
you know pretty horrific
and uh i luckily my cousin uh had
married a a guy who
uh at the time he was a northwestern uh
professor at kellogg and now he's at mit
his name's scott stern uh and he
now he focuses on ai and the
implementation of ai but at the time he
was in quantitative finance and he said
you know look this uh trying to do the
fundamental finance route is you know is
fine it's you know going to be a tough
slog but there's this new track uh
quantitative finance and you know you
you also you have your uh you have a
background in math a background in
statistics why don't you get you know a
master's degree in math or statistics or
you know something quantitative uh
because that's going i think to be the
you know the new track and the new way
of doing things and uh you know luckily
i got into a program at boston
university which was taught uh or run by
a gentleman from bulgaria andrew
liassoff who was uh you know very uh
particular about
making us really think for ourselves and
uh you know fight through proofs for
ourselves
and
yeah it was i'm glad that's uh in my
background uh for now but i think it
gave me the foundation of really kind of
diving into like a theoretical math
framework for
uh you know being able to analyze
problems uh from my own standpoint and
try to come up with an independent
opinion and uh you know i think that you
know uh the the founder of uh double
line jeffrey dunlop of the uh you know
the the honor of uh working for right
now also has a math background and he's
also known for
uh you know taking uh independent views
on things and i think
he's you know i think there's something
to uh having to fight your way through
uh you know that type of uh you know a
pure science uh you know well it's
actually about i got it as a masters of
arts believe it or not it's probably
closer to philosophy right uh but it's a
mix of philosophy and science i would
say but being able to fight your way
through and come to your own independent
opinion and your independent framework
of how to you know both analyze and come
up to answers to complex problems
so yeah you know that was the path and
you know in my graduate work my
computational methods professor was also
the chief investment strategist at john
hancock financial uh it was a great
course obviously uh you know i enjoyed
it he hired me out of uh out of the
program to come work as an analyst for
him and i remember you know sitting next
to his secretary and you know i had a
very small cubicle at that point
as a young analyst and i didn't really
know what to expect and he
basically started giving me what i
viewed as more homework assignments but
they were kind of uh you know let's call
it markowitz or you know black leader
men efficient frontier you know type
projects where we were looking at
different asset classes different
correlations and you know changing
correlations and you know how we wanted
to allocate uh you know from a macro
economic standpoint uh you know for for
you know uh for the firm at the time uh
which just
led me into macroeconomics and uh you
know uh
my career continued from there
so um it's interesting uh a few episodes
back i i interviewed uh marlena lee
she's with dimensional funds and she
studied under eugene fama
and uh and she said that that that he
had recently conveyed to her that that
the efficient frontier was effectively
broken
and that that that it was no longer
applicable in today's market so i'm
curious of your views because you've
you've been you've interacted within
these markets since you know 2003 2004
and
what's changed about uh about the
subject of correlations because i don't
think correlations as a subject are
given enough attention
having been a former federal reserve
insider boy can i tell you that
correlations matter
uh you know when the peanut butter hits
the fan they matter a whole bunch but
what's changed about uh kind of your
approach to investing since you first
started out
uh well since i first started out i you
know have integrated uh
so i i've integrated much more of uh you
know putting fundamental views uh back
into you know what is maybe a strict uh
more of a strict mathematical framework
and i think that that's uh yeah i i i
will go back and watch your prior
interview i had not seen that one but um
i completely agree with uh you know the
takeaway that you just pointed to uh you
know first of all basing future returns
on past returns as we all know is uh you
know very dangerous i think when we look
at the world that we're in today uh you
know the shifts in policies that uh you
know are happening haven't we haven't
seen that for you know multiple decades
i mean we have to go back you know uh to
post uh you know world war ii to maybe
see some of the central bank policies
that are being put in place so it
doesn't really make sense to you know
base an investing framework uh you know
on a statistical analysis that just uses
the past 20 years also when we look at
the inflation regime and you know maybe
you could equate it to the 70s maybe you
have to go back even farther um so i i
think that you know the idea that you
know um you're going to base an
investment decision uh purely on you
know a very small sample set uh you know
it's not a wise decision now what i
would say is correlations are very
important uh you know correlations i do
think uh you know it well it
it explains how the world is currently
working and i think the most important
thing uh you know about correlations are
when they change and i think that you
know it's uh
when we go back and we start to stress
test uh you know different scenarios
everyone likes to go back and say uh
well let's see the 2008 and 2001
scenarios maybe we can say uh 2015 and
16 and 2018 were shocks as well uh but
you know i i think that
you really need to evaluate uh you know
what happens
uh when you start pushing all the
correlations up and you know it's though
it's the it's like donald rumsfeld said
the unknown unknowns that you know are
going to kill you and you know the you
know over reliance that we're seeing
right now i know there's a huge
fascination uh you know with what we
call artificial intelligence which is
just statistics like come on i you know
we we there i mean realistically like
you look at these meta classifiers and i
did them all in grad school so you know
you start looking at like you're just
layering on like a bunch of different
statistical analyses that you know are
like kind of maximum likelihood
estimators and you know they need to
take an average of what that outcome is
uh the problem again is it goes right
back to what you just said you have a
limited sample size that's based on
history that might be changing so um you
know going forward if uh
i i think people need to be very careful
uh about just flipping a switch on a
model and no matter how smart you think
your model is no matter how many times
you re-parameterize your neural network
uh you know it's not going to uh it's
not going to save you uh you know from
big changes in the world that are
happening that you know maybe the data
wasn't available as in robust deform as
it is today
but we can go back and we can analyze uh
you know those prior periods uh you know
where policy did start to reflect and
rhyme with today and make the you know
make our future investment decisions
based on you know uh that type of
analysis as well as you know trying to
risk control the uh portfolios sure
you know and it's uh it's interesting
you
it's interesting you bring this up
because
if anything investing in america
especially for younger investors who are
in 401k plans is it's about as cookie
cutters you could possibly get most of
them are in target date funds uh and
that is based on
a model that you describe
so uh and and it's passive in nature as
well so
uh
i i think there is a
deep disappreciation for the importance
of correlations in how
your typical investor uh gets get
started
i i could not agree more i think and
we're a big believer here that active
management and uh active research is uh
an extremely important piece of uh you
know of any investment process
uh you know i know the move to passive
has been aggressive and you know it's
this passive and really when you look at
what a lot of the statistical work is
actually doing it's chasing a momentum
factor
right like everything's momentum right
now so you know uh
and one day uh people are gonna realize
that uh they're all piled into the same
trade
and you know it may be very difficult to
get out uh you know when the time comes
and i know everybody is smarter than the
next person that you'll be the first out
and that won't be a problem but
uh you know having been in markets for
you know a couple of decades and you
know having tried to fight through a lot
of those uh liquidity moments uh it you
know i i think you're fooling yourself
if you uh you know actually uh you know
are going to rely on you know a model to
tell you uh you know when you should be
taking chips off the table because you
know basically the model that chases
momentum is going to tell you to go with
it you know at potentially the worst
time
i i couldn't agree more i've spoken with
a few people who have have really done
some great analysis on passive investing
and it is just it is frightening it's a
beast that feeds upon itself that's
never
the fed the federal reserve has never
allowed it to be stress tested
effectively um so let's let's talk about
monetary policy let's talk about because
you're alluding to
how policy
was back when the the the the treasury
in the federal reserve were effectively
married to each other before the 1951
accord
and when fiscal policy was carried out
through the monetary policy channel
which is of course in violation of the
federal reserve act which is why the
1951 accord occurred
but where do you see where policy is now
what what parallels would you draw
and and and where is it headed
yeah uh well i
i really think that you know when we
look at uh you know both monetary and
fiscal policy we're we're kind of
hitting the end of the runway here uh
you know when we look at what's actually
happened um you know we've had uh you
know purchases not only of government
securities now we have purchases of
private securities even uh you know and
this is not just in the us like i you
know i i'm a global person so you know
quantitative easing is happening and
credit
and bond purchases and the credit
markets are happening in europe they're
happening in uh you know japan japan you
know is also buying equities uh it's
also happening uh you know across
emerging markets like this
past uh you know pandemic in march of uh
2020 opened the door to all of these
expansive policies across the globe
and uh you know so far so good i guess
like you know we were able to you know
support markets uh but what happened in
the pandemic is we had uh at the same
time that you had all the purchases of
uh you know government securities and
private securities we also had a huge
fiscal uh you know impulse a huge fiscal
uh you know uh
explosion or uh you know push into
uh
people's pockets and that was a big
change from what happened uh from the
global financial crisis and i i just
want to highlight this because it's a
key change to understanding the
inflation that we're seeing not only in
the us but globally
uh today so the when we look at uh you
know quantitative easing a lot of the
monetary policy that happened in you
know 2008 uh it was pretty much focused
on you know it stayed in the banking
system via purchasing assets from banks
but then you credit their reserve
accounts at the different central banks
which is kind of funny money or
wholesale digital currency which i'll
come back to in a second but it stayed
in the banking system and allowed banks
to you know kind of use leverage in
order to engage in you know their
trading activities they were supposed to
make loans but they didn't so what
really happened there is we had asset
price appreciation because all the
liquidity stayed in the banking system
and central banks used it more for
market making activities rather than
loan activities and it did not hit the
real economy
this time around uh fiscal authorities
said you know what we're here's the
fiscal stimulus that we're we're just
sending checks out to people because
it's a pandemic and now effectively uh
monetary policy is underwriting this
and lo and behold what happened this
time around
uh inflation is a global phenomenon
inflation is uh what we saw six point
eight percent in the united states it's
five percent in the uk
you know we're in a high four handle
across europe with germany close to six
percent uh you know and then across the
globe it's a problem uh and now it's the
conundrum of our day so
when we're you know as we go into 2022
one of the biggest questions is this
growth in inflation handoff and what
decisions do policymakers in each
country have to make
and it this is it gets especially
fascinating in international markets
because unlike in the us
international markets are subject to
having the discipline of a depreciating
currency
you know if they don't react to the
inflation side and we have seen a lot of
central bank tightening internationally
uh you know over the past year and we're
just starting to see the fed and just
today the bank of england and even the
ecb's getting you know forced into the
party a little bit of you know trying to
turn more hawkish uh and ultimately uh
that's creating a very uh precarious
situation as we go into the early 2022
as this tightening of financial
conditions this reduction of central
bank liquidity globally is now starting
to pressure growth
so
we have i know everyone likes to focus
on like the the virus is the you know
main growth driver but there's another
huge growth driver that we need to pay
attention to which is uh you know the
tightening policy from central banks now
uh
i i've been running uh you know i i've
been running pretty hot there but if
you'll just allow me one more
please no no quick uh quick avenue
i think that in the next prices
central bank digital currencies and the
new digital money that we're kind of
beginning to understand and which we're
going to talk about i know in a little
bit more detail are going to become a
much bigger player in what happens in
like the next big bang stimulus whenever
it's needed i don't know when the next
recession is going to come
when it does come i really think that
that's going to be you know the new um
well that's going to be the window or
the door that opens for bringing digital
technologies uh from kind of this uh you
know uh like i guess they're they occupy
a little corner right now to becoming
more of a wholesale i think that you
will see a big re-plumbing of the
financial system uh just because of all
of the
you know potential
avenues that it opens up for you know
central banks you know to then start
implementing fiscal policy in a much
more directed way and i think that that
temptation
that you know we give governments via
the central bank that tool
will you know it's being questioned
today and you know people are going to
debate it as we're going to debate it
but when the crisis hits i think the
temptation of that tool is going to be
too great to pass up
i i will not disagree with you but let's
go back for a minute and you said that
post-financial crisis
uh that that we effectively had
wholesale digital currencies explain
that yeah so
[Music]
effectively when uh you know your
account is credited so when central
banks went out and they purchased
treasuries uh you know from uh you know
uh private bank balance sheets and then
uh you know put uh it credited your
reserve account inside the you know at
the federal reserve so you had your
excess reserves go up the excess reserve
money is only uh you know effectively
used in the banking system it's not b
it's not used you know for uh you know
any other type of transactional
settlement but it's also not paper it's
a digital currency so the you know and
it's it's fungible between banks it's
fungible it's and it's immediately
settleable so you know in the in kind of
the wholesale markets the wholesale
banking markets when you actually look
at what happens uh you you can have you
know intraday settlements uh you know
happen instantaneously now that type of
technology is uh well first of all it
provides a massive uh you know platform
with which uh you know the private
sector can you know begin to leverage
and uh you know buy more you know be
able to provide credit to each other and
provide credit uh you know to the
economy but it's also a very fast
platform for central banks to be able to
provide liquidity into the banking
system to you know either pick that
activity up or slow it down now if we
say that's the banking sector which is
great but what about the rest of the
real economy
uh that's the that's where we get into
you know the new i think this is the
block this is really where blockchain
comes in and uh you know ironically
although the you know blockchain is uh
you know allowing all this same
instantaneous low latency settlement
blockchain and the you know private
digital currency market was started uh
you know in reaction to
all of the quantitative easing that was
happening uh you know post 2008 and it
was a private uh you know it basically
was an exercise by the private sector to
say you know what we're going to create
our own little financial system
that actually you know is going to have
a lot better uh you know settlement uh
instantaneous settlement capabilities
we're going to be able both to see all
transactions on the blockchain but then
protect anonymity it's going to be
permissionless anybody can join there's
no background or credit checks and you
know no requirement that you have to you
know go to you know a a fed approved
bank in order to you know be able to
participate in this and then in certain
you know uh you know small arenas
they're trying to limit you know the
amount of currency or you know tokens
that then can settle uh you know on this
particular network and when i say
blockchain basically think of it as a
network that allows transactions to
settle and then you can have a whole
host of uh you know different things
that can settle on it from you know what
they call currencies which we can i i
think i i think the currencies are much
more of a security uh in my opinion but
uh you know they call what they're
calling currencies can settle you can
also have all sorts of new assets such
as like the nft phrase uh you can have
like you can go buy digital art
if you want to and it will also settle
on the blockchain which is you know this
private network so uh you know that was
created in reaction to you know all of
this you know the explosion in you know
really what was the wholesale digital
money uh you know from central banks
within you know the banking system and i
the
central banks have realized this and now
they're starting to say okay
uh we need to like get into this game
and either when we need to
understand it better we need to regulate
it but maybe we also need to be involved
or create a competitor system to it and
that's where the central bank digital
currencies come in
uh and the central banks now are you
know on a country by country basis
trying to evaluate
uh you know do we want to you know uh
legitimize and participate in the
current uh you know d5 network and deep
system that is set up today or are we
looking to create our own which is what
china is doing and china has completely
outlawed the you know private sector uh
you know defy system and they're setting
up their own what they call dcep which
is digital currency electronic payment
system that then is completely monitored
with no anonymity and total control by
the pboc
uh you know but it's being implemented
as a you know
new private sector digital money that
basically is settleable on their network
and it's uh you know and it's something
that they can track and control uh you
know uh
as they see fit so
you know
i hope i did a good job in trying to at
least that
and what you're basically saying is that
the public sector
is
exploiting the work that's been done in
a post-financial crisis world
on the blockchain and they're adapting
it
to their own 100
and i mean hey how great is capitalism i
mean look at when you just let you know
computer engineers run with you know
other creative minds
i i mean this is uh you know it it's
creating a new marketplace you know this
network is effectively turned into a new
marketplace and you know we look at you
know a lot of the trading that's
happening in this d5 world and that you
know d5 stands for decentralized finance
and that's the network that's the
private network that anybody can you
know go and join now you know most
people are doing it through coinbase
where you know you're starting to get
like a lot more legitimization uh you
know of this uh basically this new
financial network um you know but what
i'll what i'll say is
uh
one i think that it's been amazing you
know the
the rate at which it's been you know
people have adopted it and been willing
to put money to work in this new sector
two it's been amazing when crashes or
drawdowns have happened both in
traditional markets we've seen it in the
crypto markets the crypto markets have
not failed they've actually on just the
logistical side they function just fine
and that is like you know this was
initially created you know just with you
know let's call it was open source code
but you know shoe strings and like you
know just people kind of in their
you know in their homes and their
apartments putting it together and it
helped so i think that you know not only
central banks but also traditional
finance companies uh you know and uh
traditional the traditional banking
sector is taking notice
and i think that there is a lot of work
being done
uh to figure out like how do you
integrate like a lot of these
technologies uh into the traditional
banking system in order to you know
facilitate uh you know more financial
activity and more financial transactions
so um
you've just kind of walked us through
decentralized finance um what is a
stable coin
so the stable coin it's uh you know a
token or you know a currency uh but it's
a token that settles on that uh you know
on a blockchain network which again is
you know decentralized network but its
value is linked to another asset and the
you know most notable ones are linked to
the dollar then you have some that are
linked to the euro and some that are
linked to gold now uh you know when we
look at uh you know uh the use of stable
coins uh
it's it it's huge
uh stable coins actually uh
are on one side of at least two thirds
of all digital transactions or all
crypto transactions that uh that
happened because you know if you have
your dollar like let's say you know you
you have you put your dollars in your
you know crypto account now you want to
go buy something that the first thing
you're gonna have to do is uh you know
you can't just use
uh it you know you have to use a digital
form of the dollar and you know that's
what the stable point is
so
what we've effectively seen is uh you
know there's now a new market you know a
dollarized market uh you know so it's a
new financial market that
you know basically runs uh you know
completely cashless uh paper paperless
it's all digital
uh and you know uh it's it continues to
grow i looked it up this morning uh the
stablecoin market cap as of uh i think
it was yesterday or two days ago was
just below 150 billion it was like 148
billion and that's up from 138 billion
last month when i wrote the paper that
just shows you like this is just the the
growth that's happening is uh is
tremendous and you know i think um you
know
sitting in the united states a lot of us
just think uh you know about investing
and wow isn't this kind of an
interesting way uh to maybe look at new
investment ideas and you know gain
potential returns in the portfolio but
there's a whole uh you know other world
out there that uh you know in
international finance that focuses on
international payments and you know
payments between companies uh you know
obviously are all global now but then
even individuals a lot of people come to
the united states to work and then they
transfer money back to you know their
home country to support their families
and those are called remittances and a
lot of these are starting to go on to
you know these new digital networks
because you go to western union you go
to moneygram they're charging you you
know outrageous fees it can take time to
actually get there versus you know this
is instantaneous you know very cheap but
it's very cheap to do
so uh you know i i
i think that the merits of uh you know
decentralized finance as an
international payment system
makes a lot of sense to me and it's not
just me who thinks that other central
banks are catching on that you know
maybe this is a very interesting idea
and uh so the bank of international
settlements is actually working on a
project in asia with you know the bank
of australia the uh you know central
bank of singapore malaysia and south
africa in a project i love these names
they call it project gun bar i think
and
but what they're trying to do is create
this central bank uh you know uh
blockchain
settled uh payment system
and you know this is i think such a
novel idea because as you start to think
about
how international trade and inner
international finance works what we're
seeing now is like a lot more regional
based trade and a lot more you know
focus on you know who are close who are
domestic partners who are the people who
we actually trade with most and let's
form trade agreements with them and so
these regional like instead of having
these overarching you know one-off wto
type you know global trade agreements
we've seen an explosion recently in
regional trade agreements that are
agreements just between a handful of
countries the wto actually has measured
and shown that you know we're at 350 uh
you know regional trade agreements and
that's just continuing uh to move up if
you look at agreements that are in place
it's over 500 so ones that you know are
looking to be you know brought into
effect
so when you start to think about you
know all of this regional trade that's
happening with a potential new
technology such as you know the
blockchain
i think it has very interesting
implications you know for the long-term
outlook for the u.s dollar and its
reserve currency status well so
so your
digital dollar
so
if if i hear that word digital dollar
i
i find myself asking
what are the implications of the dollar
effectively being pegged to these stable
coins what are the implications for the
treasury department for the federal
reserve
well that's a you know that's a good
question i think they uh you know
they're
but they're the way they're looking at
it right now is uh first of all like
these are being used more and more as i
pointed to so like the volume of
transactions occurring on the system is
now reaching a status that's
systemically important so uh they need
to regulate it and what has happened
when like i i think the you know the
most important risk that they're looking
at and i'm thinking about right now is a
financial stability risk because i you
know manage uh portfolios of risk assets
and you know financial stability risk is
something that you know i need to pay
attention to of course and uh the
if all of a sudden you know just as
remember when money markets broke the
bucket everyone freaked out if a
stablecoin broke the buck and we are
actually you know it's 148 billion in
transactions uh you know as far as
market volume right now that's likely to
only increase if all of a sudden
everybody lost faith in it as you know
more and more activity picks up
you could end up in a situation that you
know people just you know begin to try
to pull all their money out of that
system and then pull their money out of
other uh you know systems and it becomes
it can you know start to cascade through
financial assets so that got a digital a
digital run
a digital run but that would then feed
through to the traditional asset sector
so i think that that is what they want
to avoid so what they're talking about
is why
should stable coins stay one for one to
the asset that they're that they've
chosen to peg to and you know the reason
should be because the underlying
collateral is one for one to that asset
so if it's gold you better hold a bunch
of gold if it's the dollar you better
hold a bunch of safe dollar assets and
you know some stablecoin providers are
doing a fantastic job of that other
stablecoin providers you know there's
some questions about
i'm not going gonna name names but you
know i think that
the you know the the the authorities
that you're referring to are taking a
hard look at that because you know they
saw what happened uh you know in uh
prior episodes when kind of these core
foundations of uh you know the financial
market uh when trust was broken that
they actually could retain their value
uh you know that that has implications
that you know will ripple through the
financial system so i again i think that
from the digital dollar standpoint
uh the fed has kind of disappointed in
you know their they were supposed to
come out with the position paper this
summer
they were supposed to yeah i know and
it's still we're still waiting on it uh
in fairness to them
i think that their their wait and see
approach isn't all that bad i think what
they're you know people are saying well
they're losing first mover advantage
like the market's going to run away from
them
well i think the stable coins are
actually kind of a good solution to keep
them out of the issue
of becoming a quasi-fiscal uh you know
tool so we had mentioned before that
this new digital technology potentially
gives the fed the ability to move from
the monetary space into the fiscal space
as far as plumbing and that's a huge
political debate that they may not want
to enter into
and if they're saying well look the
majority of transactions that are
happening right now have uh us dollar
stable coin underneath it why don't we
regulate that market why don't we kind
of watch how that happens if there's a
huge problem you know we can then you
know step in and potentially issue our
own stable coin or you know develop our
own network but
i think they're trying to take this wait
and see approach because they know
that you know once they decide like
china if they decide to go the route of
china and implement their own network uh
there's going to be a lot of pressure in
the next crisis
for uh you know from the government for
the central bank to be doing things that
you know they otherwise would like to
you know avoid
of course
um
before we before we get to
the the the potential
the potential that you see and the
potential that you see the potential
risk you see for the u.s dollar
um can you walk through a little bit of
what happened in the plumbing
of the financial system when it seized
up as the fed was trying to extricate
itself as we were going through the
process of quantitative tightening
while
global central banks suffering negative
interest rates were were packing a bunch
of money in into accounts at the federal
reserve
while currency in circulation was going
through the roof at the same time and
the plumbing seized up
yeah the plumbing seized up so
yeah you're referring to you know when
the balance sheet reduction happened and
you know the effective fed funds uh
basically the fed so
you know let me take a step back uh you
know the fed
it you know tries to control it can
control money supply it can control
interest rates and it tries to control
you know the amount of credit in the
markets uh and but that second tool the
control of interest rates the way it
does it is it just tries to control the
front end at least you know in its uh
in in its setting its policy target it
tries to control you know that effective
fed funds rate which is basically linked
to the money markets like there's a lot
of plumbing that happens in uh you know
in fit between uh the money markets that
you know kind of
attach it to where
uh you know the fed funds rate is now
that what was happening at the time is
we had seen the fed like they were
talking about letting paint dry by you
know reducing their balance sheet or
selling you know government bonds back
to dealers but then taking back you know
all those excess reserves but what it
was effectively doing is it was reducing
the liquidity with which dealers could
then you know both purchase dealers like
you know they'll use liquidity as a form
of uh of leverage to both uh buy and
warehouse uh you know uh uh
securities uh you know financial
securities and so there was a dual
action that was happening there we they
were reducing that liquidity and they
were giving them and they were just
pushing more securities on them uh
eventually uh you know as you know they
as they were going through their hiking
that you know as they were as they were
going through that cycle
you saw that the they were unable to
control uh you know the effective fed
funds rate uh you know or the overnight
rate uh they were not able to keep it
within their target band and that was
all due to you know the just their
complete lack of awareness and
understanding that the liquidity that
they were just pulling out as watching
paint dry uh you know was getting worse
and worse as they were just continuing
to push more and more uh you know
inventory uh into the markets so uh that
like that that really caused uh
the biggest the biggest problem there is
uh you know the fed is a confidence game
the fed has to maintain credibility like
why should they be able to control you
know interest rates credit uh you know
liquidity well they can control the
money supply but you know these other
elements why should they have you know
all of those knock-on implications it's
because market participants believe that
they can
and if all of a sudden they're losing
control of one of their main policy
mechanisms because of the implementation
of the policy that you know that they're
trying to unwind
well wow that that can actually have
much deeper systemic implications for
markets because if markets think central
banks are out of control
then you know you have questions about
okay what is the fair now
you know we
right now with all of the intervention
that's happening pricing is being based
off of kind of where people believe
policy can be and can be maintained
if we start to think like wait a minute
policy cannot be maintained at the
levels that central banks are telling us
and we know that you know the
macroeconomics are very different from
where the policy currently is set which
is where we are today
that poses a massive uh you know uh
potential risk uh you know to markets
and then knock on implications to growth
so
clearly the fed has waited too long i
don't think anybody doubts that and i
don't think that they
they fully grasped what what
underwriting this fiscal policy was was
going to do in terms of unleashing
you know i think other countries also
hold the fed excuse me hold the fiscal
authorities and the federal reserve
accountable for
for in some parts because the fiscal
stimulus the fiscal thrust was so
it was so mad so massive that it bled
into other countries inflation
um
so where
where do we go if we start to lose faith
in in the federal reserve how how could
this tightening cycle
play out because we've got a very flat
yield curve right now
which suggests and it's flattening
fairly fast which suggests that the fed
does not have much runway to try and
push through this tightening cycle much
less you know just just extricating
itself from from growing its balance
sheet
right so i you know i i believe that we
probably have one more uh big bang
stimulus that might work uh you know in
the global central banking system and
you know probably with a lot of these
you know new tools uh that we discussed
i think that you know what we what we're
currently seeing
is uh you know asset prices are uh you
know
very divorced from fair market value
we've seen now the implications into the
real economy through inflation uh you
know moving much higher and you know
we're going to see you know as like the
as this 2022 plays out
um you know
how much of i you know if the just the
small reduction that we are seeing in
you know the central bank policy that is
starting to reduce m2s not only in the
us but also in europe and across the
globe how much of that you know can then
start to slow down this feedback uh you
know into the real economy uh you know
on the inflation side without completely
destroying you know the the other
balance which is growth so if you know
we start to see inflation come down
because growth is coming down
uh you know i think we're we're getting
into um a fair amount of trouble now the
reason why i'm kind of wavering is if it
were just the u.s that was doing all
this nonsense uh you know with the you
know the money printing and you know
basically underwriting all the fiscal
stimulus then the implications would be
very obvious that the dollar would tank
and you know assets would eventually
like you'd have with the inflation being
a u.s phenomenon assets would leave the
u.s
but this is a global phenomenon right
now uh and even you know central banks
that have no right to do or should not
have by the you know the capacity uh to
do quantitative easing and you know this
type of uh you know uh fiscal
underwriting uh we're seeing uh you know
even in emerging market countries and
they're you know starting to unwind
they're trying to unwind it as well so
the question is you know where can
assets uh you know where does money
really run to
and i think that you know the this idea
that you know the least dirty shirt is
uh you know gonna start to play out but
this is where i think you know all uh
you know countries you know are starting
to think very hard
about you know look the amount of us
dollars that we hold and the fact that
we've always counted on the us to do the
right thing
uh you know does that make sense and
like you know if you're looking at
uh you know
when you start looking at other
countries where
they they'll say uh i i i understand if
the u.s may still be you know one of the
cleaner shirts but do i want all my
apples in that basket or you know do i
want to look at my broad balance of
payments or do i want to look at my
trading relationships
and you know does it maybe make more
sense as
you know
you know as an international central
bank instead of holding all my currency
uh reserves or the majority 60 percent
or more in the us dollar do i want to
start holding a basket of currencies
that actually reflects the trading
relationships that my country engages in
over the course of the year and that may
be much lower as we know
the us is only 20 of global gdp but it's
60 percent of the global exchange
reserves that are held internationally
just by comparison let's look at europe
europe is about you know eight sixteen
to twenty percent of global gdp and
their percentage of you know global
exchange reserves about 20
so you know that that makes uh you know
a lot more it may be a lot more sense so
i although i'm not saying the dollar
will completely disappear i think that
you know there's a potential
normalization uh you know that might
happen
because people are going to say uh to
themselves these policies
uh how much longer can they go yeah
bill maybe you say there's one more you
know potential safety net that they can
throw at
but what if i'm wrong
uh you know that i think you need to
like like
finance one-on-one you got to diversify
that basket on a fundamental level we
are going into a midterm election year
so
yeah there's there's something
for for for
whether we could
uh in such a year in such an instance
you know given what the yield curve is
is broadcasting um but so so bring into
this discussion
if you will
the international payment system
because balancing away from the dollar
how can that be facilitated
oh yeah so uh this is where you know we
were talking before i think that
uh you know right now international
payments are mostly facilitated on the
swift system and uh you know that's uh
about 85 of all international payments
via swift uh one side of them are the us
dollar and uh the the reason for that is
the majority of global trade is uh done
in u.s dollars the majority of
commodities are settled in u.s dollars
so uh and for for the longest time you
know the us has been a global leader in
providing security a global leader in
you know trying to create these you know
very large uh you know economic and
trade partnerships and you know now what
we're seeing in the past uh you know
multiple years is the u.s is starting to
you know step back a little bit from
that role
and i think you know especially with the
implementation of the post-covet
policies when you look at like you know
the fiscal trajectory of the u.s
um and you know there there's uh you
know there's just one more quick aside
maybe that you know i can i could
actually just put in here
uh you know since 2008 uh there's been
an absolute explosion
in global savings that has come into the
u.s and found its uh you know home in
u.s assets so really what that's been is
the recycling of all of the purchases
that the us does abroad
uh you know what we we give dollars and
we're buying t-shirts we're buying
computers we're buying you know now uh
get you know uh
additional uh um you know cars whatever
it is all of those dollars that are
purchased uh you know there's a choice
to be made you can either sell those
dollars on the market and then go buy
you know an asset at home or an asset uh
you know in another country or you can
take those dollars and buy us assets and
since 2008 there's been an absolute
explosion of that money coming back and
when you look uh you know i like to look
at you know we measure that i think the
cleanest you know one of the best ways
to measure it is through the net
international investment position which
basically nets out you know all of the
us purchases abroad and all the foreign
purchases in the us and that shows kind
of the balance of you know what could
then unwind so in 2008 that was about 4
trillion and it's gone up to 14 trillion
so about 10 trillion of assets on you
know this net basis have come in
uh so when you get into this new world
where you know your people are starting
to say
uh as central banks may be looking at
saying okay we're looking at you know a
business at a economic model that's
maybe more regionally focused
we've now entered into several regional
trade agreements with you know our uh
you know all of uh local countries that
you know were actively engaged with our
central banks are now implementing new
technology that moves away from swift
for fast international settlement for
all individuals and corporations uh you
know in this little economic region that
we have set
why do we need all these us dollars as
uh you know our in our uh foreign
exchange bucket and that you know
natural reduction i think you know
creates a multi-polar world
but it you know it it
i i'm not saying that the dollar will
disappear
but what i'm saying is the dollar from
its current 60 status may go down to you
know let's call it 40 or 30 percent uh
you know that would be a big transition
and you know the that potential uh you
know devaluation the potential that that
has for the ability of the us to still
underwrite all like you know global
trade and you know be the consumer of
the world and then the potential that
you know that that then puts pressure on
the fiscal authorities and the central
bank to you know start to address a lot
of uh you know the problems that you
know are building up because then people
will say well wait a minute you know the
dollar isn't just you know pegged and
stable like you you need to regain that
status by implementing proper policy
boy would we like to see that happen
so what what might what might the end
game look like
you you use the term king dollar so um
yeah no i i think yes i think that you
know uh ultimately i see a more you know
again uh a multi-polar world i don't
know if there's gonna be a new uh you
know king that's uh that's crowned and
you know i know there's a lot of
discussion about china just waiting in
the wings uh you know to potentially be
that you know the the new uh you know
world reserve currency
and i have my doubts on china the reason
that you know i i doubt it is that well
there are several reasons one the
institutional strength just isn't there
uh you know it is a foreign investor you
don't know how you're going to be
treated in a domestic court well
actually we know not well uh you know
we're finding out quick aren't we
exactly and you know as far as like how
workouts and you know uh you know
defaults and restructurings happen in
china uh you know they're big questions
to that as well but then their capital
account is closed and what i mean by
that in
2015 and 2016 china went through this
massive currency devaluation that they
couldn't control and the reason for that
was domestic
investors were taking money out because
they were saying look this seems like an
unstable model to me i want to you know
go somewhere you know go somewhere else
so what china did is they effectively
closed the ability close that capital
account to the domestic savings not
allowing it out
and you know to this day it remains
closed and actually just uh you know
about a week ago uh you know the china
state agency for foreign exchange
increased the scrutiny with which
they're looking at you know
international payments which tells you
you know that they're you know a little
bit worried that you know there there
could be some leakage there well that's
gonna tighten i mean if if the fed's
tightening that places china at risk and
china's slowing too because remember
they're implementing a whole new
regulatory regime in china that you know
has been slowing you know their economic
growth as well so uh you know
are you as a foreign investor you know
right now china says oh no we promise
we're going to keep the capital account
open for you
now that's a big uh you know leap of
faith i think there are ways to you know
participate that aren't putting your
investors at direct risk of capital
controls uh you know if you do want to
participate in china but you have to do
it through you know proxies or offshore
proxies which you know also have you
know their own slippage risks
but you know that being said for all
those reasons i you know i don't know if
it's just you know uh the dollar is
gonna you know then be replaced by uh
the chinese wand what i think more
likely is what we just discussed is that
you know
each individual country looks at their
you know broad trade what i would call
the broad balance of payments like you
know not only the trading relationships
but the financial relationships as well
and you say okay looking at the you know
all of these you know where where do the
majority of our flows uh you know our
currency flows outside of our country's
boundaries go
do they go all to the us or do they go
to a different subset of nations your
closest trading partners your closest
trading partners now you're going to
have to say some of those trading
partners currencies
i may not trust as much i don't think
they you know have as much institutional
credibility that there's risks such as
in turkey where you know that
you may have policy makers doing the
wrong thing such as cutting interest
rates when inflation's at 21 and likely
going higher so in turkey what we're
just seeing is a over 40 devaluation
this year as they continue to you know
make bad policy choices so those you
know maybe those countries you're going
to shy a little bit less and then you'll
pick up you know you'll increase your
euro or your you know dollar or your
again uh you know or your aussie dollar
allocations you know to offset it but
what's going to happen is there's going
to be a more diversified bucket uh you
know in that foreign exchange uh you
know holding by central banks which by
the way we're already starting to see
and all that is going to be you know
again uh you know uh it's
it's going to be facilitated by the new
technologies that are being put in place
that's going to offset you know the us
domination in you know kind of this
global trading uh and financing role
well i mean the implications are vast
and it's it's kind of a it's kind of a
slow bleed if you will that you describe
the loss of hedge money the loss of
superpower status could be something
that occurs kind of gradually
and methodically
as you say because these trade
agreements are increasing in numbers and
and becoming more regionalized
so uh and and again so i think
i i i mean i i think you're right but
it's uh you know the old saying of uh
you know how do you you go broke first
slowly then all at once yeah and this is
where i you know uh i want to just bring
back the idea that
all this foreign savings sitting in the
u.s
is a powder keg so yes the these these
um you know the the international
plumbing is you know slowly being
rewired you know into this multipolar
world but once the dollar starts to go
down a little bit i can see you know of
uh decisions being made very quickly uh
you know by people to either say like
when you're gonna have private
individuals and companies uh you know uh
institutional individuals taking their
money out uh and probably bringing it
back home very quickly uh and then i
think central banks will react uh you
know relatively quickly as well so i i i
hear you that yes it's like the iceberg
that it's slowly starting to chip but
then all of a sudden you know it falls
into the sea well
in the event of recession if i mean what
you're
if if you take your your logic one step
further
the treasury is going to lose its risk
free status
so treasury auctions won't be slam dunks
they won't be guaranteed because
because it's the dollar i mean and that
i mean that is kind of mind-boggling if
if you think about it from from the
perspective of somebody who's a market
veteran like yourself or myself
to have the treasury not be the
risk-free
world global asset
and you know it's interesting uh you
know where it's i still think we're you
know a little early on this trade
but just in the past uh you know a
couple of weeks when we started to see
you know a little bit of weakness in
risk assets uh you know the normal this
is we're gonna get back to correlations
the normal correlations that we see
uh you know in currency markets uh you
know between the dollar and the euro and
like the dow like normally the dollar is
a safe haven currency and goes up right
and we've been seeing you know
situations where we've had this risk off
scare and actually you know the euro's
gone up against the dollar on those days
you know now granted it's just been like
you know one it's just uh you've been
one day here in one day there so i i
don't want to make a mountain out of a
molehill right now but if we're looking
for tea leaves uh you know that that's
something to pay attention to if you
believe the thesis that you know i just
laid out well and i i it's it's it's
plausible and it's also something i
think that the world would welcome
whether we whether we as americans want
to acknowledge that or not um because
because we we take our fiscal profligacy
for granted
yeah effectively and that's that's very
true and it's you know i i don't know
how long the runway is uh that we have
left
well
speaking of which uh let's shift gears
to uh
to china and i i would i would happen to
agree with you that i don't think that
they're
in a position
uh to
to to unseat the dollar the yuan
but uh
i i had a really long interest in
conversation with leland miller of the
china beige book
and i'm interesting to i'm interested to
hear your thoughts about what 2022 is
going to bring to china uh there's
obviously some very big events that are
going to be occurring you've got you've
got the olympics and then you've got the
congress in the fall the people's
congress
so uh first of all the you know the lens
with which i'm viewing china is all
about the october november 20th national
people's congress uh 100 this is where
xi jinping is up for uh his appointment
to an unprecedented third term it
effectively you know is his it like what
it it he's assumed to you know get that
appointment and once he gets it it kind
of solidifies him as you know a leader
for as long as he wants to because this
is roosevelt moment it's it absolutely
and
what we're i think you know in order to
understand uh you know uh well
let me just stick with that so if he's
going to be appointed what he doesn't
want is he doesn't want rivals and he
doesn't want social unrest those are the
two threats to you know 100 to you know
to that reappointment and when we start
to look at what's happened recently uh
you know i think that you know you can
really begin to understand the
regulatory reset uh you know if you look
at it through that lens so
when we look at a lot of what's been
happening in the tech sector you know a
lot of that was has been focused on the
state regaining control of the tech
monopolies but then also trying to you
know
take all the wealth that's being
funneled to just a few individuals and
spread it more broadly which is you know
being defined as you know common
prosperity but i think you know the
government saw jack ma and others
starting to you know feel that well i've
economically become very successful and
now i'm going to push back on things
that you know i disagree with and you
know that was clearly unacceptable but
also similarly unacceptable was the fact
that a lot of people are being left out
on all this wealth generation
and if an opportunity to gain to allow
the state to gain more control of these
very large companies you know comes in
so you have soes taking minority stakes
uh you know uh in companies they're
gaining control of a lot of uh you know
the individual user data and then
they're able to like implement policy
where they say look you know executives
are going to get capped but we're going
to start you know paying people more
broadly that solves uh you know a lot of
problems that have happened
uh
when you think about you know the fact
we are going to have a new credit
stimulus in 2022 because uh going into
you know that
mark that november october november
appointment they're going to want to
make sure that the economy is humming
when that does happen they don't want
that stimulus to just go into a couple
people's pockets they want everybody to
feel like they're you know participating
in that wealth creation so you don't
have social unrest and then the other
thing is
we
coming out of march 2020 you had a very
large stimulus out of china as well and
as we know china's capital account is
closed money can't leave and you know
their financial markets you know are
beginning to develop more but they're
not as developed as in western countries
so we see a lot of savings sitting in
the property sector 71 of urban savings
sits in property investment and what
that did is you had a massive amount of
leverage that it built up and you know
you had a huge financial stability risk
in that sector as well as focusing on
people owning high-end properties
because you know that seemed like a good
investment rather than affordable
properties for everyone else so here
again we have like a great you know
coming together of multiple forces for
the government so you're you know you
want to engage in a credit stimulus in
2022 but you know the property sector is
over leveraged so you're going to have
to de-leverage it first so you can
actually have room to re-leverage it
going in but then you're saying hey
developers like you guys are just
building houses like so that you know
rich people can have four or five houses
for savings well no we have a social
need here so now you're seeing state
control come in and they're starting to
implement more uh you know of the policy
that they want but when the stimulus
happens it's going to again have a
little bit more room to run and filter
more broadly into common prosperity so
as you can see like if you take this
political lens and you know say all
right i'm gonna like say that china is a
commanding is a command economy it's
being run by she and his people
they're they want a smooth reappointment
and then you start working back from
there things start to make sense and i
think post olympics it's probably end of
q1 early two q two is when we start to
see credit pick back up
and then i think you're gonna have an
interesting uh you know uh reflationary
trade in emerging markets that are
linked to china because like that
stimulus you know rising tide lifts all
ships
uh you know i think that that that is
probably you know from the investment
side uh you know what you want to be
paying attention to uh so i think that
china's growth
in that whole framework what how does
that translate to markets uh you know
growth continues to remain slow in the
first part of 2022 uh and then going
into the appointment it begins to
ratchet up tremendously and that's going
to pull a lot of these china proxies
higher as well so i think you know you
still need to be cautious short term
uh i think it's a lot of people are
trying to buy the dip i think it might
be a little early
but the trade will be coming uh you know
i do think in the second half
of course the swing factor of course is
is fed policy
well that that's very true and but if we
have uh you know a tightening fed and uh
you know other tightening global central
banks and china in the you know let's
call it beginning of q1
does not uh you know engage in an
aggressive fiscal stimulus
i think the global growth
side is going to be extremely challenged
because one of the other things that we
didn't talk about
that also is going to be hitting early
is the pass passing to the debt ceiling
uh as the debt ceiling uh you know is
now passed uh
you know where
what's going to happen is the treasury
is going to start to rebuild its rainy
day fund uh you know at the fed and it's
uh you know what the you know the
treasury builds up a lot of cash to use
for you know when these debt ceiling
issues and other issues do that get it
back up to 800 billion exactly so you're
having not only are we having you know
global central banks tightening removing
liquidity we're going to also have the
build up of that treasury general
account or the rainy day fund
further pulling liquidity out of the
system as well so that's another form of
tightening that's going to be happening
in the background and i think the idea
that china you know is uh ready to turn
like i hear a lot of strategists talking
like now's the time like here it comes
and you know we saw a little tick up in
some of the you know uh some of the
credit numbers in november it was
nothing in my opinion that you know we
should be uh you know looking for a much
bigger stimulus uh later in 2022 i think
that this opening of uh the first
quarter of 2022 there could be uh you
know a lot of big waves and choppiness
uh due to slowing global growth and
global growth concerns
i've been speaking about this a lot but
people don't realize that that december
the 15th
is
for the moment at least it's the last
child tax credit that's going to be sent
out in cash that's a good point so
that's january 15th is going to come and
go without that direct deposit and and
in addition to that you've got
a lot of american families who've been
taking this cash who don't realize it's
going to affect the income tax
refund that they're not getting
at the end of january or the beginning
of february and then student loan
payments are going to kick in in the
beginning of february so
i'm right there with you on the
choppiness in the first quarter
while the fed is expediting this
tapering process and the tga is
refilling itself
right so the three the three hikes in
2022 you know i
i i would take the under if you were to
ask me today because of what we just
discussed absolutely
so is is there anything i'm missing
about about the world you see of of the
future and um
well i mean there is one there is one
question i i do want to ask though
there's one more question i want to ask
what are the implications if
eventually all the central banks have
their own digital currency so what are
the implications for
kind of the private currencies that are
out there
oh you you mean uh you know so like
bitcoin ethereum and all of those uh
well so
i think that you know uh
i as long as they're not regulated away
i i i don't view them as currencies like
i i view them more as securities and
like okay you know so like everybody
you're saying well no there's an
exchange rate associated with them well
there's an exchange rate associated with
ibm too like i can price ibm in dollars
yes
so uh you know i think that if we think
of that more as a financial market in a
financial exchange and you think of you
know these currencies uh you know as
uh you know either as securities but
securities with utility so you know
these ideas of uh you know especially on
the ethereum network i kind of like the
idea of gas fees where you know in order
to settle uh you know a transaction if
you are you know doing uh you know a
different type of token you need to pay
you know a little bit of uh you know the
ethereum you need to pay for it with a
little bit of ethereum so then all of a
sudden like there's like a business
model and you know you can start to see
you know a form of cash flow associated
with that so you know that that makes
economic sense to me and i think that
you know as long as these markets are
not you know regulated out of existence
and you're just banned from being in
them uh i think the ecosystem is already
formed uh you know for people to begin
to evaluate you know utility of uh you
know all the different protocols that
are gonna be built on so you're gonna
have you know not only uh you know
protocols such as you know as i said uh
you know tokenization just you know
security-based protocols but there's
also going to be new lending
protocols i think there's going to be
new credit activities that are going to
be placed on them because remember this
is permissionless and if you now have
the ability uh you know to say let me
secure it if i'm a small business and i
want to securitize you know some of my
future sales or some of my future cash
flows but i can't you know i'm not
credit worthy
when i go to my local bank or i go to
chase or jp morgan i can't get a small
business loan from them you know maybe
there will be you know new uh you know
avenues that have only been available to
very large companies uh issuing debt in
financial markets you know maybe these
new uh you know d5 protocols will allow
small businesses to say you know hey i
know my local baker they make really
good bread and i know that they're going
to continue to sell it even if there's a
recession so yeah i'll take a little bit
of that and plus you know i know him
personally i want to support him uh you
know there's also like ideas that you
know airline miles you you if you create
you know an exchange whereby people
could swap airline miles and you could
like you know buy them for you know a
discounted value and say hey i want to
go on a vacation with my family uh and
there's an exchange for that uh you know
they're all these like really creative
ideas that are happening uh you know in
this defy network that you know i think
have a lot of business and make a lot of
economic sense so i as long as they're
not regulated away i'm i'm excited to
see you know what comes out of it well
it would fill a vacuum right because we
don't have that much of it we don't have
the same fabric of a community banking
system that we used to have
i think about what it would do for the
productivity problem too like i mean
this is really and and you're telling me
that you would allow that to if if you
had a small like a a new small business
securitization market
you know developed on defy that any
politician would try to you know say
that it was okay for the regulators to
regulate that away
i mean it it it doesn't make any sense i
think that you know eventually like the
the speed at with which you know the
innovation is happening in d5 uh you
know i i think is uh it's amazing and i
i think that there's going to be a lot
of things that i haven't even thought of
uh you know that come up uh you know and
just make this a viable like you know
just new marketplace so i keep saying i
have one last question but um i'll never
forget when i when i worked inside the
federal reserve uh my old boss richard
fisher but always he had great respect
at the time for poland and for mexico
because they and for australia there was
kind of discipline in in central banking
your world is that of currencies and and
interest rates are there any are there
any central banks out there that are
doing it right
oh across the emerging markets i mean
you're you're seeing uh you know well
you know
uh poland's have been a little bit slow
they're starting to hike now hungary's
hiking uh you know mexico's hiking they
just hiked today uh across you know you
know across the emerging market complex
you know sans uh turkey
uh you're seeing uh you know central
banks act in a much more orthodox manner
than we are across most of the g10
complex which is by the way extremely
disappointing and you know it's
interesting when you go and meet with a
lot of uh you know the the officials and
not just the you know the central bank
governors but a lot of the staff uh you
know people at uh
at these a lot of the central banks that
you mentioned and others uh you know
they're especially in emerging markets
you know they're they they came to the
us they trained it like you know the
university of chicago they
understand you know economics on a very
deep level and they're trying to do the
right thing and you know i think that uh
you know maybe one last aside like if
you use extraordinary policy in order to
arrest a crisis and then you pull it
back and then you you know uh like move
with the market and start tightening you
know as appropriate
maybe there's a place for it that's
sound policy
it's sound policy it's when you just say
oh well now that that worked i you know
we're going to keep doing this and you
know maybe we'll get more benefit from
it
the law of diminishing returns just you
know put puts you back into that corner
which
by the way is a
is a developed market problem
uh you know yes the emerging markets be
engaged in a lot of extraordinary policy
but there are a lot of them have pulled
it back already
uh and you know as we go forward maybe
people start to say
i
like some of these uh
do do we really deserve to do some of
these emerging markets really deserve to
be in that bucket or you know maybe do
they deserve a little bit more capital
yeah no no i mean i'm i wanted to end on
a high note and you certainly did
um
look i've learned so much i know the
viewers are going to be so thankful for
all of your insights
and uh let's come back let's come back
and visit after the people's uh after
the people's congress and after the
midterms and see where we are i'd love
to have you back on bill
i i'd love to be back and thank you for
you know thank you for this i had a lot
of fun and uh you know i'd love to do it
again thanks so much take care
all right thank you
[Music]